[Musique]
un virus créé en laboratoire pour des
peuples et la planète
[Applaudissements]
dangereux vaccin pour injecter des
micropuces une pandémie créé de toutes
pièces ou encore causé par la 5g
[Musique]
ces derniers mois ses idées
conspirationnistes ont séduit des
millions de personnes
[Musique]
nul n'est à l'abri ça peut tous nous
arriver car nous sommes programmés pour
y croire
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il pour basculer réussi
cette question facile des chercheurs
partout à travers la planète
c'est un mécanisme qui peut être
déclenché en chacun on n'échappe jamais
à nos origines
jamais personne n'est complètement
logique voici antoine un comptable de 42
ans marié père de deux enfants
bon vivant il aime s'entraîner au jim et
boire un verre avec ses amis antoine
existe pas mais il pourrait être
n'importe qui d'entre nous et sa vie
s'apprête à basculer 20 millions de
personnes sont placées en quarantaine à
maroua janvier 2020 un virus en chine
causerait des symptômes respiratoires
sévères voire mortelles au verrouillage
cette ampleur c'est du jamais vu
corey virus fermetures d'écoles
annulation d'événements partout sur la
planète les mesures pour combattre la
pandémie déboule rapidement l'épidémie
prend de l'ampleur
faut être réaliste on est dans une crise
qui vaut du rite des mineurs on commence
à voir des cas au canada le québec
enregistre au premier mort et vingt
nouveaux cas de coronavirus qui devient
sérieux antoine suit l'actualité de très
près il tente de comprendre ce qui se
passe
fait ce qu'on vous dit je vous en prie a
fait capoter
je veux pas pogner soucier de ce nom
[Musique]
dans le cerveau d'antoine son amygdales
s'activent
cette petite structure est sollicitée
lorsqu'on perçoit un danger son rôle
nous préparer à réagir aux menaces
c'est une réponse à la peur quand les
gens sont anxieux quand ils ressentent
de la détresse face à l'avenir
ils essaient automatiquement de donner
un sens à la situation pour comprendre
ce mécanisme
il faut remonter de près de 300 mille
ans à leurs prix historique
l'homo sapiens faisait face à bien des
dangers de karoubi les risques d'être
tué par une tribu hostile était bien
plus grand qu'aujourd'hui nous croyons
donc que nos cerveaux se sont adaptés à
être à l'affût des coalitions hostile le
cerveau a survécu pendant des
millénaires parce qu'il a été capable de
se protéger
considérer sa survie comme la plus haute
priorité n'est pas irrationnel anticiper
les complots nous a été utile à travers
l'histoire
mais est ce encore le cas j sociétés se
sont énormément transformé depuis 2001
mais c'est peu sur l'échelle de
l'évolution
donc nos cerveaux n'ont pas vraiment eu
le temps d'évoluer eux aussi en
psychologie évolutionniste
on appelle ça le décalage
notre cerveau imagine donc plus de
complot qu'il n'y en a vraiment antoine
n'est pas rendu là
mais face à l'incertitude ils cherchent
des réponses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si le confinement enfermé chez lui
antoine passent plus de temps sur le web
le manque d'information créé de
l'incertitude et notre système nerveux
n'aime pas ça nous avons donc des
circuits spécifiques qui nous pousse à
trouver de l'information pour éliminer
cette incertitude
l'institut pasteur est accusée par
certains d'avoir fabriqué le virus sarr
skov 2 c'est vraiment moche cette page
titrée qurna virus le flot
d'informations contradictoires et tour
dit antoine méo son polo pour défendre
la démocratie
le 2 s'accroît dans son esprit cette
réaction est due à son cortex temporal
médian qui est responsable de chercher
des causes aux événements ne pouvons pas
nous préparer face au hasard dans un
sens la notion que de mauvaises choses
arrivent par hasard est bien plus
terrifiante que de croire que nos
ennemis en sont la cause
non seulement notre cerveau refuse de
croire au hasard mais il se met aussi à
la recherche d'un coupable
quand les gens ont peur ils ont tendance
à surestimer à quel point les autres
groupes ont des intentions hostiles
cette réaction est due aux carrefours
temporaux pariétal c'est la zone
responsable de la perception des
intentions
[Musique]
antoine commence à tracer des lieux
c'est un autre de long mécanisme de
survie cette attitude est contrôlé par
notre cortex préfrontal droit le
problème certains voient dénier
là où il n'y en a pas je vais l'immense
si les théories du complot consiste
vraiment avoir des connexions entre des
événements aléatoires à relier des
points entre eux d'une façon que
d'autres personnes ne voient pas bien
vilaine fans troyenne l'a étudiée il a
montré des peintures de jackson pollock
à 214 participe à certaines personne n'y
voit qu'un peu de peinture éclaboussé
sur la toile mais d'autres y voient
toutes sortes de belles formes
géométriques
nous avons constaté que ces personnes
avait aussi tendance à croire à des
théories du complot par exemple que l'on
n'est jamais allé sur la lune ou que le
11 septembre était planifiée par les
états unis
et c'est là que l'engrenage se met en
marche
demande à partir du moment où quelqu'un
adhère à une théorie conspirationniste
c'est un premier pas vers une vision du
monde où il y à beaucoup d'action en
coulisses et le public ignore
m c'est que tous ces gens des médias
officiels de la politique sont soumis
aux ordres
ce dilemme dont dix feux contrôlés pour
antoine les faits sont maintenant
claires les autorités nous cache la
vérité et cette pandémie a été créée de
toutes pièces pour nous contrôler le
confinement se prolonge plus antoine
passe de temps sur le web plus il trouve
des preuves qu'il a raison internet est
conçu de sorte à nous permettre d'éviter
ce qui définit croyances si justement ce
qui arrive antoine il est victime du
biais de confirmation
c'est notre tendance à accepter les
informations qui sont en accord avec nos
opinions et à rejeter ce qui les
contredisent readman guillou a démontré
que cela est ancrée dans notre cerveau
nous avons demandé aux gens d'estimer le
prix d'une maison
nous avons ensuite informé de
l'estimation faite par d'autres
participants
il observe ensuite leur cerveau avec
l'imagerie par résonance magnétique
si le prix donné par l'autre participant
est proche du leur
certaines zones s'activent elle indique
tout l'information correspond à ce que
l'on croit
mais si l'estimation de l'autre est très
différente d'autres zones du cerveau
sont alors sollicités ce deuxième réseau
sert à rejeter l'information vous êtes
vivant en ce moment parce que vos
billets du passé ont fonctionné donc
votre cerveau doit rejeter les nouvelles
informations qui contredisent vos
billets et c'est pas naturel c'est ce
que voulait dire non ce n'est pas
naturel c'était un travail de
professionnel un travail de sape et très
minutieux et chaque fois qu'antoine
trouve de l'information qui confirme le
complot son cerveau le récompense en
produisant de la dopamine une hormone
qui suscite des émotions positives
[Musique]
le chercheur jones capelaine l'a
démontré lorsque l'information se
transforme en conviction elle devient
partie intégrante de notre identité nous
avons pris 40 personnes avec des
croyances politiques très fortes
nous les avons placés dans un scanner
irm et nous avons confronté leurs
croyances
avec des arguments et des preuves ils ne
réagissent pas de façon rationnelle mais
y motive cela sollicite donc leur cortex
insulaire et leur amie d'anne
lou ces zones sont impliqués quand les
gens se font contredire - ils sont
enclins à changer la vie modifier une
croyance est une chose mais modifier son
identité est tout autre une fois que
c'est fait votre cerveau a intérêt à la
protéger antoine se sent menacé lorsque
ses proches le confronte il s'isole de
plus en plus ils sont tous aveugles dit
et tu oublies pas masquer ce qui s'est
produit autour du port du masque c'est
que ça s'est politisée c'est devenu une
partie de l'identité de certains antoine
n'est pas seul à penser ainsi
on n'est pas les complète et sonné juste
livrés journalistes aux autres on n'est
pas des moutons nous autres ensemble ils
s'influencent les uns les autres
l'objectif de notre raisonnement n'est
pas toujours de trouver la bonne réponse
ça peut être de vouloir avoir raison ou
bien d'être connecté aux autres
[Musique]
l'ipo question qu'on me jette un max et
au non
en quelques mois antoine est devenu
conspirationnistes radical
il ne démord plus de ses convictions qui
ne repose pourtant sur aucun fait
antoine n'est pas une exception
ces deux phénomènes que l'on voit chez
des gens normaux qui fonctionne bien
sociétés qui ont des emplois qui sont
parfois très éduqués on peut le voir
partout dans la société
alors pourquoi certains basculent dans
le conspirationnisme et d'autres pas
il y a toujours des gens qui sont très
doués pour prendre du recul et réfléchir
aux événements et pas seulement ils
réagir et puis il y a les autres qui ont
du mal à faire ça ce n'est pas de leur
faute c'est juste la façon dont nos
cerveaux sont construits nous avons tous
nos motivations essayer de nous
convaincre que nous sommes parfaitement
logique nous devrions tenter de
comprendre les motivations derrière nos
croyances
au fond c'est à ça que sert la science à
atténuer les effets de nos billets sur
notre compréhension du lit on est donc
tous conspirationnistes au fond de notre
cerveau a été façonnée et si pour
assurer notre survie
antoine pourra-t-il revenir en arrière
pour y arriver il devra surmonter les
instincts naturels de son cerveau
[Musique]